well join me now as a socialist
commentator Owen Jones Owen you been
sitting there patiently your response to
Mark regive there a grotesque inversion
of reality I mean the thing about
Israeli spokesperson like that is if I
was told the sky was blue I'd go out the
window and check just to be sure what
did he say that's wrong um for one thing
talking about um the hospital being used
as a terror base now let's just bear in
mind that Israel's spokespeople have a
long track record of lying through that
back teeth when they shot in the head
for example Shireen Abu akley they said
for months and months and months it was
Palestinian gunmen it wasn't they shot
her in the head James Miller a brilliant
British documentary work uh filmmaker
shot dead 2002 by the Israelis years
later of course you wouldn't believe
Hamas and their version of events either
would you well I that's why I depend on
what Aid agencies of the United Nations
are saying on the ground which is that
Collective punishment is being Unleashed
against the Palestinian people I mean
look we can see already the evidence
they've been um unveiling for what they
said was a a terror Hub including
showing CDs and a computer what they've
done to that hospital is firstly because
they cut off energy in a total Siege
which they justified by saying they were
fighting Human animals which should be
considered genocid or rhetoric has been
condemned as such well it should
certainly be condemned and they should
not have the ability uh Israel to cut
off water and power
and about his Collective punishment just
can we agree under AR 33 that's against
the law it's a war crime can we AG I
think we should have some consensus I I
would I would argue you're heading
towards Collective punishment when you
do that you're heading towards
Collective punishment when you cut off
energy or water to the en ofation except
to play Devil's Advocate and to give
their side of it which I've heard
repeatedly take the issue of fuel they
want to try and get fuel in the Israelis
as they've said to the hospitals to the
humanitarian side of this but they know
that Hamas are taking that fuel and
using it for their military Hospital
authorities who should listen to have
rebutted those accusations look what we
what's happened here is babies right now
are gasping for breath and suffocating
we've had several nurses and patients
shot dead in fact this whole hospital
has been described by medical staff as a
Mory you don't know just quickly when a
hospital just quickly when a hospital
becomes a mass grave when dozens of
decomposing bodies have to be buried in
a mass grave in a hospital we're talking
what you said can I just quote something
you said about about pettin and and I
think this was very wise you said in
March 2022 I'm seeing a genocidal
monster killing women and babies and
maternity hospitals as we sit back and
let him do it why was it so disgraceful
but you were right you were right to
here's the difference why why you see
this hospital is they're not the same
Theory let me explain uh because the two
are in my opinion morally very different
in one case Vladimir Putin's illegal
invasion of Ukraine he was committing
war crimes having legally invaded a wait
a second let me finish having invaded a
sovereign Democratic country here it was
Israel that was invaded by a vast number
of terrorists who uh murdered over 1500
innocent men women children they
kidnapped 240 people including babies
children Holocaust of so my point is
morally there is a massive difference
morally it's a massive difference now
the question of the hospital wait a
second the question of the hospitals is
this to me they have so far produced
some evidence of Hamas operating inside
the hospital for me so far as a
journalist trying to be fair and
impartial I don't think as you've heard
me say to Mark Regan I don't think I've
seen enough evidence here which says to
me this was a sprawling command C but
there is a moral difference between what
Putin's doing in Ukraine and what
Israel's doing to defend itself against
Hamas isn't there hold on is there no no
AB no sorry this is the difference okay
if you if you want to talk about that or
trying to separate them for a Ukrainian
ordinary civilian being killed or for an
ordinary Palestinian child being killed
both equally none of them none of them
did anything wrong we agree on that
don't we we absolutely agree on that now
when we're talk when you repeatedly
denounce Putin for his genocidal
behavior in Ukraine do you stand by that
do you think that's a genocide well it
doesn't matter what the what the basis
for what the course does no no no no no
no no no no Pierce in terms of what
actually is happening we can talk what
about the massacre the obscene Massacre
of a thousand isel's doing
genocide let's talk about genocide let's
talk about genocide why is it let me
tell you the difference between gen let
me let me put something to you and you
come back at me and tell me if I'm wrong
Hamas from its Charter onwards and from
the spokesman said last week is
dedicated to the eradication of Israel
and killing as many Jews as it can
possibly kill that is the purest
definition of genocide intent that you
will ever see and they executed it on
October the 7th as best they could now
what Israel is doing in response and
they've been very firm about this and
the international courts will rule as
they these are these are very long
questions they're not I'm making I'm
answering a point and I'm putting one to
you right in my estimation they are
qualitatively different what Hamas is is
publicly what is they doing is genocide
what Israel is doing is not genocide
there's a difference between well Israel
you could say both Israel and Hamas have
engaged in genocidal and murderous
rhetoric and I'll give you an example
yes
they I can't is It Uncensored or not let
me let me quote let me quote what the
the Israeli authorities have said
Benjamin Netanyahu when he quoted amalec
the scriptures what does amalec say it
he he quotes amalec when they attacked
the Israelites and what God told the
Israelites to do was to destroy every
kill every man woman child and livestock
if I would put it to you an islamist
leader was quoting a similarly genocidal
passage from the Quran you you would not
I would say hesitate no no we haven't
just no you had a lot I'm going to
respond just quickly Israeli officials
said that Gaza will end up being a city
of tents with no building standing that
they are that they are attacking for
damage not for accuracy the agriculture
Minister Avid dict he said we are
rolling out a new nacba a nacba is the
mass expulsion 700,000 Palestinians in
1948 this is why hundreds of genocide
Scholars people who are actually unlike
q and I
experts in the field of genocide studies
fear that a genocide is taking place and
the difference between Israel and ham is
Hamas does not have the capacity to wipe
at Israel Israel is wiping off the map
that's the point but that not you've
actually exposed the weakness in your
argument Israel does have the ability to
kill everyone in Gaza tomorrow and
they're not doing it in fact well hang
on what they're doing and it's
indisputable they are issuing a number
of warnings repeatedly to people to go
south wait and stay out of Northern Gaza
right and then they're pulverizing it
with air strikes and now they've gone in
on the ground and they're waging battle
with Hamas Fighters terrorists right no
hang on hang on so my point is this
Israel could if they wanted to kill
everyone in Gaza they decided not to do
that is your defition genocide is where
you want to kill everyone sorry sorry
your definition of genocide because in
Ukraine Vladimir Putin hasn't killed
every last Ukraine that simply not
happen no no no no he hasn't and and nor
has he stated his intention to do so and
nor as brutal and barar actually sorry
Vladimir Putin absolutely by illegally
invading a sovereign country and
indiscriminately bombing anything in
front of him indiscriminately bombing is
waging a form of genocide wow
indiscriminate bombing Gaza more than
two hirosima bomboro on East London in
the space of five weeks let me ask you
no no no no no you've said Ukraine no
I'm going to have to put this to you
okay 15,000 people have now been killed
now by the Israelis estimate in Gaza one
in every 200 people in Gaza have now
been killed if you were to adjust for
population in Ukraine that would be
300,000 Ukrainian civilians 300,000
there's been a terrible death tots
estimated by the UN 10,000 civilians
have been killed since February last
year in the space of five weeks a
country with a much much smaller
population has had a much higher de has
had a death toll higher efficieny than
that that in how can how can it be how
can it be that you call that genocide
but when you have nearly half the entire
civilian death toll of the Bosnian war
in a country which is twice the size in
terms of population why isn't that
genocide B well I've just answered your
question by saying if Israel wanted to
commit genocide they would simply VAP so
Russia they would VAP Russia they would
nuke they would nuke Russia Russia wants
to take over Ukraine yes they want take
over Gaz and it will kill any number of
ukrainians men women and children in
that processable to the only death rate
in is much higher the only reason it
hasn't that actually Ukraine has a large
military supported by countries like the
United States and is putting up Russia
has nuclear weapons Russia by way
Ukraine gave their up Russia has an
armed for let me ask you what no no
you've got to accept this hang no no a
far lower death rate in
Ukraine as expained why you haven't
explained why yes I have let me explain
Israel have made it clear didn't hear me
Israel have made it clear that they
intend to occupy permanently yeah they
and which they should not be allowed to
do and what did the what did the Israeli
Ministry leaked intellig what what did
the intelligence my interview of you not
your interview of me well I think let me
answer you let me answer you well let me
ask you two questions which I asked
Jeremy Corin just get these off the
table do you believe Hamas is a terror
group yes if you engage in violence
against civilian population that's
terrorism I wait don't don't do
supplementaries let me just ask you this
second question which I asked him and
she couldn't answer should her mass
remain in power if I could wave a magic
wand then no obviously there' been
independent no let me finish there' been
independent Palestine free of Israeli
rule with a secular Democratic movement
in power the difference I agree with
when you courageously stood against the
Iraq War and you you were courageous for
doing so so what was the argument put
against you that you wanted to keep
Saddam Hussein in power even though he
gassed his own people the Kurds in
commit genocide many would argue that he
had invaded his neighbor and that he had
uh massacred the Shia when they rose up
in 1991 now your argument against that
was that what could happen next would be
far far worse and you were right that
wasn't my argument well that is but that
is the AR did you want to keep s in
power don't tell me what my argument was
I know what it was I was edit of the
paper that waged the campaign did AR I
did not believe that they had produced
any evidence that Saddam Hussein had
weapons of mass destruction I thought he
had nothing to do with 911 therefore we
were waging a completely irrelevant War
which I thought would stir up absolute
hell in the Middle East and you know
what I was right and actually most of of
The Architects of that war now concede
they were wrong it was a horror story
from start to finish but what it did do
it Spar the rise of Isis and what the
world did with Isis was say this crosses
a moral line we have to get rid of them
and we went after Isis in places like
Iraq and Syria and other countries and
in bombing the hell out of Isis a lot of
civilians K you just slipped a lot of
very important history there wait wait a
minute no no that's not what happened
well that is what happened no that's not
what happened one of the consequences of
the IRA war was that Isis became a very
powerful for a short period of time
Global Terror Force committing atrocity
just correct your hisory but in wiping
out Isis pretty effectively we also
killed a lot of civilians no what
actually happened what's the moral
difference between that and what
Israel's doing Gaza you just revised
history what we were told that Al-Qaeda
was perhaps in League with Saddam husin
that was one of the justifications of
invading what actually happened after
the invasion was that it became a
playground for Al-Qaeda who you've
missed out of notice know no and what
talking about we know alqaeda what
happened for example is fuia the city of
fuia in Iraq these the Americans went in
and they mased people protest against
their Rule and many of those Sunny
populations ended up in driven into the
arms of al-Qaeda a brutal counter
Insurgency program then resulted in
resulting in Mass Slaughter of innocent
Sunny civilians and from that Fury and
anger something even worse than Al-Qaeda
emerged just as Isis yes AG that was no
I'm saying that's exactly what we're
saying I didn't give every detail of the
journey I misunderstood you've
misunderstood they engaged in a brutal
counterinsurgency I know the story
offensive against Al-Qaeda and that
caused something worse to emerge just as
in Afghanistan to just in as Afghanistan
we had two decades of occupation let me
listen we running two decades of
occupation and the Taliban emerged
stronger than ever the same applies to
both what happened in Iraq and
Afghanistan because if you brutalize a
population you will turn them into
terrorists talking or extremist dra them
to their arms you make a lot of good
points I agree with a lot of things you
say right always have done actually I
find the way you say them as you do move
me quite annoying but that's fine you're
allowed to and we're uncensored come
back I want to end if I can with some
kind of look we've agreed Hamas is a
terror group we've agreed they have to
go how do we actually get peace here
well firstly we have to deal with the
underlying causes of what's Driven the
Palestinian people in the case of Gaza
in Gaza into the hands of Hamas which is
starting in 1948 the ethnic cleansing of
the Palestinian population in the naar
with 700,000 driven from their homes
murderously I ad then and hundreds of
thousands of Jews were driven from their
homes before in Palestine well they were
driven away from Arab count hold on this
they were driven away from Arab
countries yeah from Palestine Jonathan
freed wrote a very good piece about this
you know what if you go to the history
there's just calls on both the pales the
Palestinians were driven from the home
700,000 of them and then we had the
illegal settlements of colon ation
including in the West Bank were
completely un remarkable already
Mass legal settlements and as well as as
Amnesty International as Human Rights
Watch and betm describe it the Israeli
human rights organization a system of a
party but if you keep brutalizing the
Palestinian people ridding them of their
freedom and you end up now in Gaza with
with parents picking up the the burned
dismembered remant of their children
there will never be P I agree what I
would say to that is that the on the
Arab side they have had multiple
opportunities to do a peace deal not
least in 2000 with Arafat and he walked
away no what happened there go what what
was what were the concessions because no
the truth is Bill Clinton who helped for
wait a minute who helped Forge peace in
Norman Ireland brilliantly with Tony
Blair and with the others involved there
that actually Arafat they had peace in
their grasp and as Bill Clinton said to
him I'm going to end up being a failure
because of you and that's yeah well and
that of History again not just from you
on this but by Bill Clinton because they
demanded for example N Land swaps for a
ratio fav come back again I love no
seriously this this conflict is not
going away no it's going to continue
raging the War I think you're an
important voice in this we should keep
talking about it okay well out good to
see you see
you